I'm just a person that was very lucky,
I did something that I liked
since I was a kid,
which was writing code.
Getting into computers at the time
it wasn't a popular thing.
Oren Dobronsky, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Very good.
Thank you for having me.
I am blushing.
I'm a huge, huge fan,
I have to say.
I'm a huge fan on several fronts.
First of all, your Hummus helped me
get through many final exams
at Stanford, not just me,
but about all of my dorm.
It's Stanford's favorite restaurant,
I have no doubt.
The second thing is the direct flight
between San Francisco and Tel Aviv.
I believe you had quite an important hand
in making that happen.
So, my father, myself
and everybody else,
really thank you for that.
But more importantly than that,
Oren, you have an incredible,
streamline of entrepreneurship endeavors
that you've had.
Most recently, an incredible unclear,
given that I can't wait to hear about it.
But also a pretty prominent,
now TV persona,
through the Sharks in Israel.
So, wow.
Oren, how did you do so many things?
I don't know.
I guess I can't help it.
That's the right answer.
I love that answer.
But tell me how you started.
You went to Mamram, and from there
how does this happen?
So, I consider myself very lucky.
That's the bottom line.
I'm just the person that was very lucky.
I did something that I liked
since I was a kid
which was writing code.
Getting into computers at the time
it wasn't a popular thing.
My parents used to shout at me,
you know,
"Why don't you go out and play?"
And I said, "I just love it."
And I used to play a lot
with my computer.
And then it was very natural
for me to go to Mamram.
And when I was leading the army,
it was '96
and I really had this vision
of what the Internet can happen.
And back then, in Israel in '96,
very few people thought, you know,
about the upcoming revolution.
So, I started my first startup in '97
just because I felt that again.
This was like I had
to do something about it
and I created my first startup.
It was the first Craigslist.
I didn't even know about Craigslist,
but I still get to Craigslist in Israel.
A bulletin board.
And I mean, the year wasn't,
the market wasn't ready.
So, I had to close that the year later.
It was a big heartache.
And thank God I had a girlfriend
at the time who told me,
"You must work on the second one."
I told her, "You know,
it doesn't work this Internet."
And she said, "No no no. You must do it."
And so I started my second one.
And then I basically hit the jackpot.
I came up with a concept of toolbar.
And I hold the patent over toolbar
and that became history.
Unbelievable, literally everywhere.
That is Hotbar, correct?
Right. That was Hotbar.
We had an estimate that
we had like one
in every four computers in the world
had our toolbar installed, at the time.
That is just unbelievable.
Talk to me a little bit
about that resilience
of being a young entrepreneur.
Your first startup fails.
With the inspiration and motivation
from your girlfriend,
you moved on to the second startup
and it skyrockets to the point
where you are literally in a quarter
of the computers in the world.
What was that transition like?
How do you fathom that transition?
Well, you know, even then,
the mindset, it was so,
everything was so,
every day there were new things.
People didn't really know.
They would know today.
It's funny today when you start stuff,
there's so much material
to read about and to learn,
you know, even when you went to Stanford.
At the time there was nothing.
Anyone who did anything
in the Internet space,
it was all discovered.
It was a totally like the Wild West.
I think about it this way.
You know, we needed to invent,
you know, from the methodology.
And what are you going to do,
how you're going to do, there were no tools.
You need to build everything yourself.
Obviously, there was no cloud.
So, we needed really to figure out
what we were doing.
And, you know,
it's also the market's modification.
Then 2000 came and everything tanked.
And we needed to, you know, stay afloat
in a very difficult year.
Unbelievable.
Different times.
I have to say that, you know,
I spent five years in 8200
which was a phenomenal experience.
I'm sure a very similar
to the experience in Mamram.
And then, going to California
and seeing what's happening there,
literally every corner at Stanford
there's a class teaching you
how to start a startup.
Every kid that walks
on campus is thinking,
"What am I going to do?"
In 97, 98, that wasn't the case.
You didn't have a class
in every corner helping you,
which is amazing.
No, there was nothing.
You know, I needed to explain that
what I'm doing is
I'm a computers company
in a special field called the Internet.
It was kind of a subset
of being in computers.
Wow.
That is just unbelievable.
I want to fast forward
the journey a little bit.
And I want to make sure
that we very soon get clear,
giving them all
your most recent endeavor.
But you have two stints along the way
that are very irregular
for the average, you know,
Silicon Valley entrepreneur.
The first one is something
that we can all thank you
for allowing us to travel back and forth
to Tel Aviv and San Francisco.
That is a startup by itself,
it sounds like, because
that was quite a journey.
Tell me a little bit about that.
Well, that was totally
an irrational thing to do, right?
So, I was living in the valley.
I moved to the valley in 2008.
So, first I moved to New York in 2000.
I lived there eight years.
I already sold my startup Hotbar.
I exited, I made some money
and I had another one.
That one also went well.
And then I moved to the Valley.
And then living in the Valley,
having to take this daunting flight
to Tel Aviv once or twice a year
when you need to stop somewhere
and collect your luggage
and move it to a different terminal
and all kind of crazy shit,
I just said, "This cannot be the case."
So, you know, I contacted United
and they said to me,
"You know, Oren,
there's just not enough demand."
And I said, "Well, this is not possible."
There are so many startups here,
so many Israelis.
But not just Israel here,
there are so many American startups
that are, you know,
I have a location in Israel
that need to fly people
from Google to phase,
I mean, anyone I knew.
Yes.
There's a big, big center in Tel Aviv.
And so, I decided to do a petition.
And, you know,
and about 10,000 people
signed a petition committing to flight
of 36,000 flights roundtrip tickets.
And with that, I basically came back
to all the airlines and I said,
"Guys, there is a demand."
And there was a phase there, you know,
that United just got tired of me.
And, you know, it's funny because
after they launch that direct line,
two months after that
they had this national convention,
they have an annual convention
with all the managers meeting United.
And the guy who is in charge
on route planning is going to the stage
and he says the following.
He said, "I don't know how these Israelis
remodel all our algorithms.
But this is the number one flight
in our network
and we couldn't see it."
That is really unique.
How do you explain that?
Is it that did they fly under the radar?
You know, look, I think that they look
at Tel Aviv and San Francisco
as two random locations
like Boston and Rome, okay?.
I told them, "No, these are two tech hubs
that the companies who work
in these places
will definitely use your business class."
Yes.
"If they have an option to fly direct,
they will not fly in direct
because of price."
Yes.
You know, maybe it's my fault
that the prices went so high.
But United said, you know, "Okay.
So, let's have a bigger business class.
Let's charge a lot of money."
And guess what?
People just were willing to pay any price
to have a direct flight
instead of wasting a day.
I mean, it's a very simple market.
Right?
On one hand, when you have
the regular flight,
you're applying to the larger market,
most of it is business and leisure.
But here, not many people
take a vacation to San Francisco.
Right?
So, I think that's just [--].
But that was minor compared
to the innovative nature
of Oren's Hummus
that I you know,
I have to say, Oren,
I'm in Tel Aviv,
I ate hummus here every day.
And somehow I find myself
missing your restaurant.
No, no way.
You are too sweet.
But you introduced the Jaffa.
Right?
The off menu Jaffa dish
that one of the waiters told me about.
And since then...
So, tell me a little bit about
why start a Hummus Restaurant?
So again, you know,
as an entrepreneur,
you just can't help it.
But you always see
what needs to be done.
You always say, what is missing,
what can be done with this,
what is not, you know.
Here I have to admit
that not only that
I saw how much it was missing,
I myself, miss hummus.
Yes.
I used to go eat hummus before
I board a plane to go to San Francisco.
And when I come back,
I used the first thing to do
is to go to eat hummus.
Yes.
And I said, "Let's have a place
basically for the Israelis."
I didn't think about it too much.
I just wanted a place for us.
And my wife thought at the time
that I was a little bit crazy.
And I told her,
"You know, Nancy, you're right.
Consider it like a midlife crisis.
But we'll have a place."
And she has experience.
I was very lucky to have her
because she has a restaurant experience.
And so, she helped me open it
in the beginning because
I didn't know what I was doing.
And the one thing
that I insisted on is that
you will keep it like
the best quality possible.
We were not aiming into profitability.
We say we are going to,
let me give you an example.
So, from day one,
we would import the grains themselves
from Israel in a boat.
Think about it.
The grain needs to go halfway
around the world to be on your plate.
And the tahini,
we bought the whole pita machine
because there were
no decent pitas in the dairy.
So, it was really,
how would I say it,
it was not a financial project,
it was a project
that comes from the soul.
And, you know,
some people are saying
that this is the recipe for success.
I don't know if that's true.
But it really came from a place
to do the best,
the best food I can do.
My only goal was, I mean,
other than financing it,
my only goal was to make sure
that the taste is the way I remember it.
To be as authentic, because some people
along the way suggested, maybe we should
adjust it to the American palate.
And I said, "No way.
We are going to do it exactly
the way it is in Israel."
And I think that's where the charm is.
That suddenly there was
such different taste,
such a different experience.
I mean, when we opened,
we had Americans who came in.
And the fact that you use your hand
to rip the pita and scoop it,
it was like mind blowing.
A hummus eating guy.
We explain how to do it
because people didn't know how to do it.
And you know, somebody told me
this is the best place for a date.
You just come and you share and you
I mean, it's unique.
So, when you say that you miss it,
when you're in Israel, you know,
in Israel there is a hummus
in every corner,.
And people are like diehard fans
of one hummus
and they will never step
into another hummus.
California was a desert.
I mean, if they were anywhere near
a decent hummus,
I wouldn't have the opened.
The only reason I opened is that
I couldn't find anything decent.
And Oren, of course,
I have to mention
that the missing ingredient
from everything that you mentioned
which exists there,
is when you walk down
University Avenue or Castro,
you hear Shlomo Artzi
coming from one of the restaurants
and that just warms the heart
of every Israeli that walks there.
But Oren, we have to...
And that's totally my wife.
That's totally my wife.
Yes.
That's genius.
We have to fast forward
because we only have 20 minutes.
We have to still talk about Clear Giving.
And we completely skipped
over the fact that
you're a huge TV celebrity
in Israel now, known as a startup guru,
investing as part of the Shark Tank show.
But we'll leave that
for another discussion.
Oren, after all of that
incredible success and endeavors,
which I have to say
that the most inspirational part for me
is not the toolbar
and it's not the startup in '97,
it's about this lifelong mentality
of being an entrepreneur.
And it's about your motivation to go
and fix whatever you see
happening around you.
And I think that is just so incredible.
And that's a mentality
that I wish for myself,
I wish for all my friends,
for everybody that's surrounding me.
So, I really want to thank you for that.
Talk to me a little bit
about Clear Giving.
What happened that you said,
"Now I want to make a social impact."?
Yeah.
So, Clear Giving is actually
a continuation of a project
that I did for many years before that.
So, when I had some money to give
and I really started to struggle
where I'm giving it.
I felt that just giving it
to the first random nonprofit
is just not the right thing.
You need to treat it with respect
as if this is, you know,
you are serious about
getting it to the right places.
And none of the non-profits,
none of the organizations
that I worked with
offered the level of transparency
that I would use to, I usually
give a big sum of money
but you don't really know
what happened to it.
You don't know what impact,
you don't know where it goes,
you have no control of where it go.
So, for many years
I used to employ an individual
who used to find me families in need
that I could support them directly.
So, after doing that
for more than 10 years,
I basically decided, you know what?
How about taking it to the next level.
How about productizing it
and basically doing, again,
what I wished would be,
what I started giving,
which is basically
someone who could build for you
a portfolio of families.
And that's basically
how I started Clear Giving.
I basically said,
"We will make a website
where we first of all,
we screen families
that need support in Israel.
We get them all from the HaRevaha,
which is the social services in Israel,
then governmental social services.
We screen them,
they need to pass certain criteria
before we upload a certain profile
of them on the website.
Obviously, it's anonymous.
You cannot know who they are,
but you get to know their story.
So, you as a donor,
you can go into the website
and choose families you want to support.
Amazing.
We initially report it
like adopt a family.
Some people felt it's like too much.
So we said, let's call it Clear Giving.
Another big feature
other than knowing
who you're giving the money is that
we set a 100% of the donation
goes to the family.
So, we separate the operation,
of course, we have dedicated donors
for operational cost.
At this point, it's me.
But in the future,
it can be other people as well.
But the vast majority of donors,
if they give a dollar,
then the dollar goes to a needy family.
So, that gives you a feeling
that you are not, we are not,
there's no conflict of interest.
I like to say,
it's the biggest bang for the buck.
You give $10,000,
$10,000 go to families
and there's nothing being taken out.
I have to ask because first of all,
regarding that last point,
it's fascinating because,
because when they do take a cut
or a margin from the donation
then obviously, the more they market
the more they make.
And then there's a conflict of interest.
But I have to ask about the distinction.
A lot of the nonprofits
that I'm aware of
and a lot of the organizations,
you give them the money
and they promise
that they'll disseminate it
to those that are in need.
But you don't have that story.
You're missing that individuality aspect.
And when you're mentioning
that you're telling
the story of a family,
even though it's anonymous,
I feel like I'm giving to that family.
So, tell me about that business model.
You picked it.
So, I want to make that,
I want to give the benefit
to you as a donor
that you know who you helped.
It's like if it wasn't for you,
they did not had food on the table.
Right?
I mean, this is literally,
you chose them, you picked them
and your money is going to them
and you get reports to the last cent.
You know where it went.
Another important thing that you said
is that we believe
that helping people in need
is something that, you know,
people who need food,
people who need clothing,
people who need basic, basic things.
I want to help them.
You know, there are many,
many nonprofits today that help
on a higher magnitude.
We will build a big matnas.
You know what a matnas is?
A big school.
Like a community center, yeah.
We will change poverty.
You know what?
I think it's important.
But I think it's also important
to help the poor person
who cannot feed his kids
or who cannot buy his daughter,
you know, [--]
because he doesn't have money.
And just think about the drama
that these people are living in.
If you can help them get something,
you know, so basic
that we all are taking for granted.
I think that's a big mitzvah.
I think people need to think
about it when they do philanthropy,
they need to say, you know,
I have big, big goals
and I have, you know,
immediate help that I can offer.
I like to say it's like,
you're planning a financial portfolio.
You sometimes invest in high risk,
you go to startups
and you go to make equity,
but you also have bonds
and with low risk products.
And the same thing here.
You need to think long term,
but you also need to get fish
to the poor person standing at your door
and is asking. You cannot tell him,
"Oh, no, I'm going to send the kid
to the university."
You know, that's nice.
I'm going to give a tuition
to a kid like a scholarship.
Yeah, that's nice.
But what about the young people
who need the help right now?
So, I like to think
that this is the solution.
What we started doing
and I think it's valuable to say
is that we started as really offering
this service to anyone
with a credit card
so people could, you know,
give $10 or five dollar,
whatever they want, they can give.
And it's a monthly thing
that they support a family.
By the way,
whenever we get to $200 a month,
that's what we want to raise per family
then that family goes off the site
and now we will help another family.
Wow.
So, that's the quota.
But my point is that
we recently started doing basically
a service to bigger donors.
So, people who want to give me
$10,000 or $20,000.
What we said is that we will build
a portfolio for them,
think about it as a managed portfolio.
Yes. I was just about to ask about that.
So, if $200 a month, right,
times 12, it's 24.
For $2400 a year,
you can basically take
a family in need,
families with very difficult stories
and basically move them
into a totally different place.
It might not change them.
It's not that they are not poor anymore,
but you take so much drama,
bad drama out of their life.
You give them support,
you give them the basics.
Now, whatever extra money they have
they use in buying something.
They buy new shoes for their kids
or stuff like that.
But if you may even think about it,
for almost 11,000, right?
10,800, you help five families a year.
I don't think other nonprofits
can offer something like that
because usually, again,
when you think long term,
then you need to invest more.
When it takes longer
and then things are more costly.
But here, for $11,000,
you basically can help five families.
And this is what we are aiming now.
We are aiming now
for people who basically come to me
and say, look,
I'm giving you a budget,
think about like a bank account,
and you will build me
a portfolio of families.
These families will stay with them.
We are not going to switch them.
They will be your families.
We will update you
what's going on with them.
From time to time
they might write you a letter.
But basically you will know
that you support these families.
I think that's remarkable.
When you mentioned
about the families
not being poor anymore,
but at least
they'll give them comfort.
I'm a huge fan
of the pyramid of Maslow.
I remember when I learned about it,
first in middle school,
I understood it so well.
I was going through
a heartache with a girlfriend
and I couldn't function
because I didn't have
that baseline field.
And I can only imagine
how difficult it is for a family.
And I'm very privileged to come
from a family where I never had
to worry about food on the table.
But by giving them the food,
by giving them some comfort,
you're allowing them
to think more critically
about how they can then
improve on the other things.
And it's like you're a rolling ball.
It's a spiral.
I love it.
Think about the shame
of the parents that need to look
into the kid's eyes
when they cannot afford
buying them shoes.
You know, when I think about it,
I'm starting to howl.
I'm tearing up right now.
Because I have kids.
If I would have a situation
that I could not afford
buying them something
that is pretty much basic
that other kids have,
you know, this is a terrible situation.
So, the $200 a month
is as small as it sounds,
makes a huge difference
for these families.
Unfortunately, there are so many families
here in Israel, now, especially you know,
we didn't speak about that,
but now with the corona, you know,
I returned to Israel for a year.
I took a gap year now
in August for a year
after 20 years in the States.
And, you know, I was shocked.
The corona literally took families
who were already in a good place
and put them in a bad place.
Those that were in a bad place
it put them in a place
that you cannot imagine.
So, the level of poverty,
usually you don't see it,
because when you stay Tel Aviv,
Tel Aviv is like another country.
It's like the Silicon Valley.
It's like the state of Tel Aviv, yeah.
Right.
When you move out of Tel Aviv
and you go Holon and Lod and Ramla,
you know, all these places,
you cannot believe
what stories we found.
And again, I would say, you know,
if now is a time,
if there was ever a time
to give to help people directly,
it's now.
Now it's not a time to say,
You know what?
I'm going to save for your tuition.
I'm going to change
the education system.
Now is the time to just give.
Oren, thank you for all the amazing work
that you're doing.
You are touching literally
so many lives before this,
after this, during this.
Thank you very, very much.
Before we leave,
I have to ask you
the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Oh, my goodness.
Well, I'm definitely entrepreneur.
Yeah.
But I would like to say
that I'm a world benefactor.
That's my goal in life.
A world benefactor.
Yeah.
I want to make this world
a better on many levels.
That's how I see myself.
Entrepreneur, world benefactor.
I love it.
Oren, toda raba.
Thank you very, very much.
Okay my friend.
Thank you for having me.
Of course.